bonjour je m'appelle jacques joubert je
suis professeur de l'histoire à
l'université de bordeaux
alors nous travaux à bruniquel ont
permis d'abord deux dates et des
structures qui était connue depuis les
années 90 on est revenu sur ce site pour
essayer de les comprendre de les
interpréter les analyser et surtout de
les dater
elles ont à peu près 180 mille ans et là
il ya trois conséquences majeures par
rapport à notre connaissance de données
des retards d'abord c'est
l'appropriation du monde souterrain par
une humanité différente des hommes
modernes ça c'est complètement nouveau
jusqu'à présent c'était 35 mille ans
avec les premières grottes ornées
d'europe deuxième point important c'est
la maintenance du feu parce que pour
aller en milieu souterrain à 330 mètres
de l'entrée il faut être capable de
maîtriser le feu et de le maintenir avec
des lampes ou des torches portable et le
troisième élément ce sont des structures
relativement complexe aménagé qui ont
été pensés selon un plan avec un emprunt
de matériaux choisis bien sélectionner
des astuces architectural et qui nous
révèle les structures relativement
complexe et pour cette période nous en
avons très peu